salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique pendant cet été j'ai
relu un livre qui s'appelle mai 68
l'héritage impossible écrit par le
sociologue jean-pierre le goff
ce livre propose un bilan critique des
années 68
je l'avais déjà lu il ya de nombreuses
années quand je m'interrogeais quand
j'étais d'extrême gauche et que je me
posais des questions sur la notion de
bien et sur le progrès se livrent à
l'époque avait été extrêmement utile et
bien pour remettre en cause mes
croyances et me permettre de me rendre
compte
et bien que les notions de bien et de
progressisme évolué avec le temps et que
ce qui était le bien une époque n'allait
plus forcément à une autre par exemple
la dépénalisation de la pédophilie dans
les années 70 est donc en relisant ce
livre que je conseille d'ailleurs à
toute personne de gauche qui
s'interrogeraient un petit peu sur ses
propres valeurs pour remettre pour qu'on
a un petit peu de recul sur celle ci est
donc en relisant ce livre cet été je
suis tombé sur un chapitre sur le
féminisme qui à l'époque n'avait pas du
tout percutée et dans ce chapitre jean
pierre le goff et bien cite notamment
des textes de féministes qui explique
avoir tué leurs enfants mongolien et
quand je dis tué leur enfant gaullien ce
n'est pas un jugement de valeur sur
l'avortement
c'est réellement au terme légal elles
ont assassiné un enfant qui était né ses
textes sont parus dans la revue les
temps modernes de jean paul sartre donc
une revue intellectuelle de premier plan
et donc j'étais intrigué par ces textes
et j'ai cherché à les trouver
malheureusement ils sont absolument
introuvable sur internet
ils ne sont même pas dans les sommaires
trouvable sur le site de gallimard qui
est dit et la revue et donc pour les
trouver il y en a tant de parler il faut
avoir lu le livre de jean pierre le goff
puis réussir à trouver les archives des
temps modernes en version physique
heureusement l'université de tours où
j'habite à ses archives et donc j'ai pu
retrouver ces textes qui sont en fait
une sous partie d'un texte plus large
jean pierre le goff d'ailleurs lui
considère que ses textes ses récits sont
un ensemble de différents récits de
différents meurtres d'enfants mongolien
personnellement en lisant et relisant
erreur relisant ses textes
je considère plutôt qu'il s'agit en fait
d'un récit à plusieurs mains d'une
communauté affective comme il y en avait
à l'époque qui ont exécuté qui ont
assassiné un seul enfant mongolien
toujours est il que ces textes nous
présente le crime
sa logique et les arguments idéologiques
qui vont avec
je vais donc me contenter de vous lire
quelques extraits de cette de ce texte
sachant que maintenant il va être
accessible sur internet puisque je vais
le numériser et vous mettre notamment en
lien sous cette vidéo donc je ne sais
pas où je le mettrais à ce moment là en
téléchargement ou sur la page facebook
de la chaîne mais comme ça vous pourrez
le lire intégralement sachant que c'est
un texte assez long c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu dire simplement quelques
extraits significatifs et notamment le
récit est bien du crime lui-même qui a
été assez détaillée et j'espère donc que
vous lirez vous même l'intégralité du
texte est également que que vous les
diffuserons et suite à cette lecture que
je vais faire d'abord j'ai ensuite vous
donner un petit peu mon ressenti surtout
cela même si je pense qu'en fin de
compte toutes les personnes à peu près
normale ont le même ressenti sur sur ce
genre de récit est sûre ce qu'étaient
ces arguments féministe à l'époque c'est
parti je t'ai tués nous avons tué moi et
ceux qui t'attendait par amour pour toi
et par respect pour l'homme que tu ne
pourrais jamais devenir pour l'homme
pour nous pour la vie sciences qui ne
s'est pas guérir médecin lâche
inconscients qui repoussait le choix
difficile lucide humain de refuser la
vie à ce que vivre destine
inéluctablement à tous subir la honte
la maladie a contrainte l'impuissance
mental les déviations affective médecin
[ __ ] qui préférait bousiller les
familles aiment plutôt que de remettre
en question votre moral et votre
pratique
oui j'étais attaché à toi mon enfant
quand je te regardait derrière les
vitres du centre des prématurés
puis quand tu étais avec nous je n'étais
bien qu à côté de toi le jour la nuit
j'ai su à tout moment que le seul acte
d'amour que nous pouvions faire pour toi
pour nous
la vie c'était à mort et je pouvais
vivre cet amour et cette détermination
presque avec sérénité parce que je
n'étais pas seul parce que nous étions
nombreux à vouloir la même chose
pourquoi ils naissent parce qu'on n'a
pas le droit de tuer un être vivant
il paraît qu est ce qu un être vivant il
y a des tas d'individus qui sont tués
par tous et on met au monde des enfants
mongolien qui n'auront jamais la
possibilité de se révolter de lutter
pour mieux vivre parce qu'ils sont
totalement dépendants en naissant de
gens qui les prennent en charge
et ils le resteront on a cherché des tas
de médecins qui puisse nous aider mais
ils ont eu tellement peur qu'ils se sont
tous des filets on a décidé de le tuer
avec tous nos amis de le tuer parce
qu'il ne devait pas vivre
on l'a fait ensemble on était malheureux
mais sûr qu'on avait raison
on n'a pas commis un crime on a
seulement fait une chose nécessaire
après ça a été long car en fin de compte
ce qu'on a été obligés d'organiser
c'était un crime parfait
au début on croyait qu'il suffisait de
donner un produit anesthésique pour le
bébé et de lui en donner un peu trop lui
de trouver le médecin qui serait
d'accord avec nous pour signer le
certificat de décès le bébé ne
souffrirait pas et nous n'aurions couru
aucun risque du côté de la justice parce
qu'un médecin qui signa certificat de
décès ne risque rien tout au plus on
peut le convaincre d'une erreur de
diagnostic
et comme il aura été d'accord avec nous
c'était qu'il n'y avait pas pour lui de
problème moral mais voilà rien de tout
cela n'a été possible parce que tout ce
qu'on a vu les médecins il leur manquait
toujours quelque chose soit le droit de
donner le certificat de décès soit
d'être couverts complètement du côté de
leur carrière soit d'être d'accord soit
d'avoir pensé qu'un tel acte soit
possible soit que même n'aurait pas osé
le faire et c'est alors on a cherché
dans les bouquins de médecine à la
bibliothèque au chapitre infanticide la
méthode qui ne laissait pas de trace
après la mort ou à l'autopsié
on a vu que c'était l'étouffement et
c'est ce qu'on a décidé la nuit ou de
l'aventuré a été très dur on avait
décidé d'appeler le médecin au petit
matin à l'heure du premier biberon
comme si les parents en se réveillant
pour le donner avait découvert le bébé
étouffé à 11h au dernier biberon on le
lui a donné avec les gouttes de
somnifères et quand on a vu à ces
réactions qu'il dormait profondément
on l'a couchée sur le ventre sur un
grand oreiller dans lequel sa tête
s'enfonçait dans son sommeil il tournait
la tête de côté pour se remettre à
l'aise
il aurait alors fallu que nous le
maintenons attendions comme ça on a eu
peur de cette violence de le voir mourir
sous nos mains l'idée de sa mort ne
suffisait pas à le tuer lui ils
voulaient respirer
alors après avoir enroulé tout le rayer
dans des couvertures étroitement serré
on est sorti de la chance
et on a attendu à l'aube il n'était
toujours pas mort il respirait
tranquillement dans son paquet souvent
dans la nuit ils se mettaient à crier et
ce n'était jamais le dernier cri alors
on a ouvert son paquet il dormait et on
a appliqué sur son visage un plastique
il a fallu le tenir étroitement serré et
tout regarder pour que tout s'achève il
a étouffé alors presque tout de suite
comment avons nous pu faire ça comment
avons nous pu écouter les cris on
croyait que ce ne serait épargné
je crois que c'est parce qu'on est tous
devenus la même terreur en écoutant les
cris du bébé
il ne restait plus qu'un quart d'heure
et puis à aucun moment l'un d'eux nous a
pensé que c'était à l'autre ou à
d'autres d'exécuter l'acte violent
chacun était concerné par la mort du
bébé mongolien comme par la vie d'un
bébé qu'on aurait à réanimer
alors on l'a tous fait chacun
responsables des autres l'amour et la
solidarité entre nous c'était notre
société à ce moment là on n'a pas fait
un acte clandestins coupable parce que
solitaire mais tout le monde n'a pas les
moyens de tuer un enfant mongolien sans
ennuis avec sa conscience ou avec la
justice après on a pensé à des mères qui
ont peut-être fait la même chose tout
seul clandestinement qui ont été
contraintes peut-être à encore plus de
violence qui sont beaucoup moins
protégés par leur classe sociale et qui
sont peut-être en prison mais maintenant
on veut le publier pour aider à ce que
personne n'ait plus jamais à faire ça
pour que ceux qui ont la compétence
technique et le pouvoir juridique
empêche de vivre en pleine conscience
des bébés mongolien qui viennent de
naître au lieu que ce qu'ils voulaient
vivre avec un enfant soit obligé de le
tuer de le laisser dans des instituts de
devenir des parents anormaux vivent avec
des enfants anormaux voilà donc pour le
texte lui-même maintenant un petit avis
personnel je trouve que ce récit est
assez assez effrayant parce que parce
qu'il nous dit du progressisme
on est habitué par par l'histoire qui
est la nôtre à rattacher la logique
eugéniste à l'extrême droite la plus la
plus radicale et au nazisme mais là on
voit clairement avec ce texte qu'on peut
aussi prôné l'euthanasie des malades ou
des personnes déficientes mentales avec
des arguments purement de gauche ce que
nous disent ces féministes dans ces
textes c'est que
l'indic l'handicapé le trisomique autres
ne sera jamais un individu autonome
qu'il ne pourra jamais lutté pour ses
droits et donc qui ne pourra jamais être
émancipé et donc cet individu n'est donc
pas conforme à la doctrine de la gauche
et doit être éliminé là où le nazisme
voulait éliminer les handicapés au nom
de la préservation de la race ces
féministes nous expliquer qu'on peut
éliminer des handicapés au nom d'une
forme de pureté de la classe et d'une
logique d'émancipation
d'ailleurs puisqu'on parle de génie sme
il est vrai que l'on rattache souvent
cette logique à l'extrême droite mais il
faut aussi savoir qu'au début du 20e
siècle
certains courants de gauche il était
également favorable cette logique
d'ailleurs d'élimination physique au nom
du progrès et de ceux qui sont déjà là a
été réactivé il ya une dizaine d'années
en 2012 par deux philosophes qui
proposait notamment et bien de légaliser
ce que ea play l'avortement postnatale
c'est à dire clairement l'assassinât de
deux nouveau nés au nom est bien du
bien-être de la famille ou des personnes
qui sont déjà là donc il faut se garder
d'une logique manichéenne qui nous fera
croire que bien l'élimination physique
d'une personne est l'apanage d'une
certaine forme de droite radicale toute
idéologie un moment eh bien peut sortir
du champ de l'humanité ce qu'elle estime
ne pas correspondre à l'humain idéal
selon ses propres critères
en tout cas j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura intéressé je vous invite tous
pour vous faire votre propre opinion et
bien à lire l'intégralité de ses textes
et à les diffuser s'il vous s'il vous
interroge cette vidéo est en tout cas
maintenant terminée si elle vous a
intéressé n'hésitez pas à la partager et
à vous abonner à la chaîne et sur ce il
ne me reste plus qu'à vous dire à la
prochaine